in today's video we're going to be
breaking down archicad 26 to an absolute
basic level if you've never used arcad
before in your life this video right
here is for you well in a rather fitting
turn of events for this video in
particular I've just gone ahead and
recorded this entire video realized the
audio was not recording so today we will
break down our CAD for dummies including
me and go through this for the second
time in a row hopefully this time it'll
be a little bit more concise and better
articulated so let's dive on in what
you've seen when you open up our cad26
regardless of the template is you'll see
a number of windows open on either side
to the left hand side which you can drag
out as you see fit we have our main
toolbar for creating everything in 3D
and 2D on the right hand side we have
our Navigator as well as individual
areas of our view map our layout book
and our entire exporter as well for the
purpose of this let's stay to the
project map let's not Dive In Too Deep
just yet you'll also see I have a number
of extras activated so if we come up to
our window at the top go to toolbars
you'll see everything that I've
activated if you'd like to go ahead and
activate this for yourself in the
palettes I've also activated the
renovation and the trace reference as
well I've placed my tracing reference up
the top right hand corner my Renovations
in the bottom right hand corner now
let's dive into creating some very basic
3D architecture so you can understand
the principles let's start with our
walls and make sure that we are on our
ground floor if we zoom in to our zero
zero zero point which is this little X
in the corner we can click once to start
dragging and drawing a wall if we tap
the P button we can flip that wall
however we like and if we hold the shift
button it will make sure it is dead
straight clicking again will activate
the second portion of the wall if for
whatever reason your wall clicks for the
second time and finishes up the top in
the geometry method you can change how
you like the wall to operate in this
case I have it set to a polygonal wall
which allows me to click multiple times
so let's continue to to click shift once
more finish off our wall and align it
with the edge if we click the third time
and just before we finish clicking off
that wall we can see that this wall is
12
068 millimeters long but for whatever
reason really wanted to make it five
meter box we could just simply type in 5
meters press enter and it would create a
five meter long wall in this instance I
don't want that press the backspace
button finish it off we have our
beautiful wall created almost instantly
if we try to select one of these walls
you'll see they're grouped so hitting
the Escape option G or alt G allows you
to ungroup so you can quickly activate
just one section of that wall option alt
G again regroups them having these all
selected you'll see they are on a
structural load-bearing walls layer they
can go on whatever layer you define as
purposeful and fit for purpose we also
have it as just the generic wall shell
we can change that to whatever we like
say we want 100 Mil insulated plaster
brick it will automatically change our
wall type so we don't have to go ahead
100 times Flip and Change if we want the
brick on the inside rather than the
Timber on the inside tap that P button
and it will automatically change tap
that P button again it flips it once
again the best thing about 3D Bim
software is you can simply come into 3D
and you'll quickly see those four lines
that we drew have automatically come up
as a 3D object we can manipulate it
change it in 3D or we can change it in
2D however we really like so coming back
to our ground floor plan you're going to
see we don't really have a slab level or
footings level so if I press command 7
we'll activate our story settings by
default we have a couple stories already
created but we have a ground floor and
that's really about it what I want to do
is insert one below let's call this
footings let's go minus 100 millimeters
and let's also include a roof layer now
pressing OK you'll see on the right hand
side our organizer has changed to
refresh collect those changes but our
window has also changed so double click
on the ground floor will automatically
take you back to where we were a minute
ago get it this far into the tutorial
today you've probably already noticed
the desk map behind me the best thing
about this tutorial today is the very
simple fact that matte and a series of
other mats are available in the first
link in the description down below but
otherwise if you're enjoying the
tutorial so far make sure you hit that
like button to smash the Subscribe
button and if you have any questions
along the way either drop a comment down
below or join our Discord group chat the
Discord group chat is completely free to
join and it is filled with architectural
professionals students and everybody in
the field from around the world we now
want to go ahead and draw the slab below
because obviously you don't want to just
fall through the bottom of your building
so command down will move this up and
down this organizer on the right hand
side command up command down however we
like staying on the footings floor
tapping our slab button right clicking
on ground floor show is trace it will
beautifully replicate that butter paper
effect that we're so used to with 2D
manual drawing and give us that
projection of what is on that level we
can select that for any level have or we
see fit it is just in this instance that
we need the ground floor so let's zoom
in click on the edge of our brickwork
zoom out Zoom back in Click again on the
edge of our brickwork we've drawn what
seems to be a square but if we come into
our 3D you'll see that that square is a
full 3d slab if we select that slab we
can then do whatever we want with it so
command T will open up the slab
selection settings if we want to change
the type of slab we can change it to an
insulated concrete floor with 10 mil
tile press OK and there we go the
material has changed as well we've
changed the profile and the material of
the slab if we go command C again to
open up those settings and let's say we
didn't like those tiles we can click on
override surface material search for
tile let's say we want a 600 by 1200
tile click OK and there we go we've
updated those tiles very rapidly and
very easily on the other hand this slab
is sitting quite low you can see the 10
millimeters of tile a little bit of
screed in the concrete below so if we
press the command D button it will
activate our move tool we can select the
blue reference line click that once hold
shift and drag it to the underside of
the brickwork so now our tiles actually
sit on the inside of the brick and our
concrete slab is what the actual
structure is sitting on that's getting a
little bit technically detailed and it's
not that important when you're starting
out an arcad but it is good to know that
you can move these slabs however you see
fit you can also just click on the slab
click on any one of those nodes a
floating toolbar will automatically
appear you can then hover over it to see
what each one of these options does and
it will tell you what they do if I
wanted to offset all edges activate that
and then let's offset it by one meter by
typing in a meter it will simply shrink
that slab in like all other software
control Z command Z will undo your last
action option and command or alt and
command Z or then redo that last action
as well so like every other software it
is very basic from an undo redo
perspective if we double click back on
our ground floor plan we now have four
walls in the slab we don't have any
doors we don't have any Windows arcad
makes that stupidly simple so on the
left hand side again you'll see we have
our doors and our Windows let's click on
our door command T open up those
settings and it'll give you a variety of
doors available on the left at your
disposal without having to go and
re-change any of the door styles so
let's say I like that door I click OK
and then I simply click click drag drop
wherever I need it to be ideally I like
the sun to be on the outside and then
place it wherever I like to work so if I
want to swing in or out as long as the
sun is positioned in the correct space
it doesn't matter the same principle
applies to the windows so select window
open the command T settings control T
settings select which window you like
let's say I like that one for whatever
reason click it once click it again
and continue that process until I've had
enough of creating Windows we're coming
to our 3D option view settings you'll
see that I've created multiple doors
multiple windows in a matter of seconds
I don't have to redraw it I don't have
to change it it's all updated in real
time now this window right here let's
say for whatever reason this window I
don't like the material of it command T
opens up the settings once more up the
top we have three different viewpoints
and settings of how this window will
actually be seen in 3D so let's say we
go to the generic 3D model let's say we
don't want the main sash to be a top
hung mirror we want it to be a bottom
hung window and we don't want the side
light to be fixed we want that to be a
tilt turn window if we then click on the
title of this layer setting we get a
variety of different settings which you
can go through in your own time as you
see fit but let's jump to model
attributes and then we can go ahead and
change our material
for whatever reason let's say we want
that to be a metal steel window so we
just simply change the materials of what
we want to be steel it's all changed
press ok
tap escape and that window is now a
steel window now you'll also notice that
I've only done that for one window I
haven't done that for the rest of the
windows and it would look really odd
it would be extremely time consuming so
click on one window press command C go
through all those settings again and
update it instead I'll hold the option
button click on my window once hold the
option command button and then click on
another window and it will automatically
copy and paste all of those settings
from one to another in a matter of
seconds the same principle applies to
doors and windows let's say we just add
a French Leaf press OK and then we want
that door to be the same we just repeat
those same steps hold option once click
hold option command click now so far we
have four walls windows and some walls
but no roof so let's double click on our
roof layer right click show is Trace for
the ground floor so we still know what
we're drawing go to our roof plan and we
can select either the single pane
geometry or the multi-pane geometry in
this case I'm just going to create a
very basic hip and Valley roof so let's
select this one I don't want it to be at
45 degrees pitch that's a very steep Hut
so I'm going to drop that to 25 degrees
and I want it to be on the actual roof
level which is zero then I'm simply
going to draw another Square instantly
we have some sort of shape created come
back into 3D see what we've done and we
have a full 3D house in a matter of
minutes now it's all well and good that
we have a 3D model but how do we
actually document that how do we take
that further so now let's jump back into
our ground floor plan and zoom out a
little bit you'll see we have four
markers around this house these are our
elevation markers and if we want to move
them we can press command D when we've
had them selected and move them
individually to wherever we really like
them to be on the page so now if I zoom
back in you'll see my elevation markers
are quite close if I double click on my
elevations on the right hand side you'll
see a 2d projection of that elevation
perfectly done and updated as you work
the story settings on the left and right
are projected from our Command 7 Story
settings by unticking these boxes here
and pressing OK they will completely
disappear if we go command 7 again and
only want to show our roof and ground
floor settings for some sort of
perspective and scale press OK we'll
understand that that is three meters
above and that is exactly what we've
drawn a bit of an advanced technique if
you go command 7 drop that down to two
meters
press OK it will automatically drop your
roof level squish it down and adjust
that because in this instance this wall
command T open up the settings is linked
to our roof we can adjust and change
that height instantly without having to
go back and repeat all of those steps so
let's go back to command seven repeat
that in the opposite direction let's go
five meters and there we go our walls
have instantly stretched all the way and
maintained their roof position bringing
it back to three meters for proportion's
sake that's what we like our house to be
and we've gone ahead and created our
first elevation we usually do a lot of
work in these elevations in 2D
unfortunately so if we come down to our
documentation tools along the bottom
left we can go to our polyline and start
drawing a line so let's point to this
roof double click on it Escape click on
that polyline let's activate an Arrow
Head change that Arrowhead to whatever
we want it to look like and change the
color to whatever color we'd like then
we can scroll down find our text tool
come across type in roof whatever you
want to type in it's completely up to
you and drag and drop that text box in
the polyline just like any other text
box in any other software you have
alignment tools you have color tools all
at the top to your disposal you can
change the text height from two
different meals to three mils command D
to move that text box around and do
whatever you want for this entire
project now on an elevation typically
you annotate only architectural elements
you don't go ahead and document
structural or instead your document is
your roof color your roof tiles your
roof shingles whatever they are your
window frames your window selections Etc
you wouldn't go ahead and go trust roof
to manufacture specifications blah blah
blah you'd stick to just the
architectural side of things for the
structural side of things we come back
to our ground floor plan and hit our
section viewpoint on the left
let's simply draw a section right
through this middle of the house the
arrow that activates after you've double
clicked is showing a projection of where
you want to look so let's say we want to
look that way of the house click once
and our section is created you'll see
that a little drop down arrow appears
here in our Navigator as well and that
section has automatically been created
again if we zoom in like I mentioned
before archicad has automatically set up
intersection priorities so our wall will
sit on our slab and it will cut through
that tile and screed so it is
automatically drawn correctly for you
now sections like I mentioned a second
ago are a structural detail you want to
go into some structural information and
you don't really want to see any of
these colors so if we come back ground
floor activate our section command T we
can go to our uncut elements click
nothing press OK and then come back to
our section
to automatically change everything to a
very detailed black and white image
without any colors or pretty pictures if
we were doing this for a presentation
purpose that would be different but in
this instance it is more for a
structural detailing point of view but
you might be thinking at this stage wait
David you've got a box with nothing
inside it well if I double click on my
ground floor plan I can then simply go
back to my wall tool and change my wall
type to whatever I'd like so let's go
to a 50mm block work cavity let's draw
some random walls inside let's subdivide
this space however I want I have no idea
what this building is but that is not
the purpose of this tutorial now we have
rooms then we can come into our object
on the left hand side open up our object
tool and select what we need to Showcase
inside let's say we need a toilet we
double click on our toilet press OK drop
our toilet in repeat those same steps
for a shower and a vanity Basin and then
we have three objects for plumbing now
if we select all three objects by
holding the shift button you'll see that
they're an Interior Furniture now
they're not Furniture in at least in my
experience they should belong under
mechanical electrical Plumbing under the
plumbing layer then we want to move them
into some sort of unique position
command or control D and place them
wherever we see fit if we want to rotate
command e hold shift allows us to rotate
command M allows us to mirror if we
click once or twice and there we go
we've got now a little bathroom at the
back of this other room that I have no
idea what it is if we then want to put
another door in we repeat those same
steps drop a door and that's not the
right door for this instance so open up
the door command T let's find a
different door that one looks good let's
make it solid press OK door done so
let's say we want to just see this
toilet let's go Marquee select the
darker one so we see everything up and
down select inside right click show
Marquee in 3D and now we have our toilet
Market in 3D with our roof above our
walls drawn our slab down and we can see
just that section tapping escape a
couple times right click show all in 3D
quickly brings back our entire house now
you might be thinking why those layers
so important and why am I going on about
them already now let's say we don't like
this roof command or control L opens up
our layers let's type in roof untick our
roof press OK that roof disappears and
you can see everything a bit better
let's say I don't want to see my
Plumbing let's repeat that plumbing hide
okay all that plumbing is gone now it
isn't gone gone it isn't deleted it's
literally just hidden from plain sight
so then if I come back in and undo those
moves we can then repeat back to our
original what we saw a second ago now
let's imagine you've done everything
you've created your sections you've
created your elevations you've put all
the information you need to you want to
export it as a PDF you want to come
across back to your viewmap organizer
and double click on the publisher set
archicad by default sets everything up
so double click on ground floor plan
you'll see that a ground floor plan has
already been dragged and dropped
positioned on that page perfectly if it
isn't for whatever reason you can come
back to your Navigator drag drop and it
will import whatever Viewpoint you've
actually requested in if you want to
know more about how to create your own
title blocks and how to export to PDF
make sure you check out out my other
videos because I've gone through that in
detail but today is literally just a
very basic scenario of how to get from
nothing to an exported PDF in a matter
of minutes speaking of export or PDF
there's multiple ways to export to a PDF
but one of my personal favorites is to
actually activate the organizer tool so
let's go up the top window palettes and
open up our organizer you'll see that we
have a number of layouts already created
publishing sets views and entire
publishing set so for me personally I'm
going to tap the new button and I'm
going to go PDF exports double click on
PDF exports to open that up create a new
folder let's call this sketch01
and then I want to drag my ground floor
and my elevations directly into that
space I can then right click on that
folder publishing properties let's save
that to my desktop press OK make sure I
merge them to one PDF so you don't get
all the pages individually unless you
want that tap publish wait a few seconds
for it to export out find that document
in your desktop or wherever you've saved
it scroll through and there you go
you've created a full 3d model in our
CAD exported to PDF ready to print in a
matter of seconds anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did make sure you check out the
playlist to the side of me with more
great architectural content if you love
the video make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below but like
always I'll see you next Monday